ultimately the goal is to ease the
guidelines and open things up to very
large sections of our country as we near
the end of our historic battle with the
invisible enemy you go on for a while
but we win and win I said earlier today
that I hope we can do this by Easter I
think that would be a great thing for
our country and we're all working very
hard to make that a reality we'll be
meeting with a lot of people to see if
it can be done
Easter is a very special day for many
reasons for me for a lot of a lot of our
friends that's a very special day and
what a great timeline this would be
Easter is our timeline what a great
timeline that would be my first priority
is always the health and safety of the
American people I want everyone to
understand that we are continuing to
evaluate the data we're working with the
task force and making decisions based on
what is best for the interest of our
fantastic country in order to defeat the
virus we must continue to be very strong
your resilience and spirit has been
inspiring to everyone right now this
virus is attacking 149 countries but
everybody looks to us and they're
watching us
and I'm very proud to be your president
I can tell you that there's tremendous
hope as we look forward and we begin to
see the light at the end of the tunnel
stay focused and stay strong and my
administration and myself will deliver
for you as we have in the past let me
provide you an update on critical
preparations and supplies in a war on
the virus through FEMA the federal
government is distributing more than 8
million n95 respirators 14 million
surgical masks and many many millions
more under order and they'll be arriving
soon 2.4 million face shields
one point nine million surgical gowns
13.5 million gloves and more than four
thousand ventilators to the areas of
greatest need have already been sent and
we have four thousand being delivered to
New York the federal government is using
every resource at its disposal to
acquire and distribute critical medical
supplies the core element of this
strategy is my executive order
authorizing the use of the defense
production Act which as as you know
already been activated actually a long
time ago quite a long time ago private
companies are heating are called to
produce medical equipment and supplies
because they know that we will not
hesitate to invoke the DPA in order to
get them to do what they have to do it's
called leverage you don't have to you
use it from the standpoint of actually
it's been activated but you don't have
to use it but the threat of it being
there's great leverage and companies are
doing as we ask and companies are
actually even better than that they're
coming through and they're calling us
and it's been really something to see
this morning
Ford 3m General Electric Healthcare are
making tremendous numbers they've
already started respirators ventilators
and face shields they're working
together we didn't have to exercise or
utilize the DPA in any way the fact that
we have it helps but we didn't have to
and for the most part we won't have to
we're receiving full cooperation from
companies with the understanding that
the federal government stands ready to
compel cooperation if need be
we haven't found that to be the case
it's been really amazing to see these
big strong powerful in some cases very
small companies family-owned company
step up and make a lot of great product
for what we're going through and what we
will continue to be going through for a
while the Army Corps of Engineers and
the National Guard are building for
hospital facilities in New York
at the Javits Center which will be
operational very soon they've already
started in addition they're building
four separate medical facilities in
different parts of the state we're
dealing with Governor Cuomo on that so
you can have four hospitals and four of
medical facilities at the highest level
to have really incredible facilities
temporary but incredible we're also
deploying the US Navy hospital ship and
that will be arriving in New York Harbor
in the not-too-distant future it's
finishing its maintenance they're doing
a very big maintenance and what we did
is we condensed it very seriously and as
you know the other hospital ship and
these are incredible ships it's already
on its way to Los Angeles so we're in
frequent contact with state and local
officials and getting a lot of work done
we're likewise building hospitals in Los
Angeles we're working also the state of
Washington we're working with the
governor of the state of New Jersey
building a medical facility a hospital
facility and doing a lot of work I want
to thank the people from FEMA the great
people from FEMA and also the Army Corps
of Engineers secretary minuchin and the
members of my administration continue to
work closely with Congress I'm pleased
to report that we are working to pass
the biggest and boldest financial relief
package in American history senators
will soon hopefully vote on a two
trillion dollar bill that will deliver
direct cash payments to struggling
Americans no fault of their own this
came out of nowhere nobody can imagine
this even happened but it's not their
fault we want to protect and we will all
of the things that a person needs
protected and a family needs protected
we're working on job retention loans for
small businesses and extended
unemployment insurance for laid off
workers the legislation will also
include billions of dollars for
additional resources for our
is and really heroic these are
incredible doctors nurses brave and
hospitals as well as support for
hard-hit industries such as the airline
industry and the cruise ship industry
which employed tremendous amounts of
people and obviously sir very important
functions beyond that with very tough
protections for the American taxpayer
the loans will be very secure and they
will be very profitable and at the same
time they'll bridge they call them
bridge loans in many cases they'll be
bridging these companies back into very
good health some of them are very
important companies said four weeks ago
didn't have a problem I'm also confident
that the Democrats will do the right
thing I feel very confident they're
working very hard together right now
Republicans and Democrats and they're
getting very close to a very fair deal
and a great deal for the people of our
country today as you probably saw the
Dow surged over 2,100 points and see all
time record history of the exchange this
is very encouraging and I think part of
the reason is they are looking at what
is close to being passed and I think a
very big part of it is they see that we
want to get our country open as soon as
possible they see we're working very
hard on that that's a very big factor I
think in today's historic game the
legislation developed in the Senate is
the first step to restoring confidence
and stability to America's economy as we
look ahead to the time when we can
carefully and responsibly reopen our
country for business and we hope that's
going to be very soon now one wish your
Americans that we have a team of public
health experts we've gotten to know them
as well as I know them they're great
people
incredible talented they love our
country also economists and other
professionals working to develop a
sophisticated plan to reopen the economy
as soon as the time is right one based
on the best science the best modeling
and the best medical research there is
anywhere on earth our great people have
been
especially when it comes to our public
health experts and officials have been
helping other countries dealing with
other countries constant touch with
other countries helping them out because
many of them have never seen anything
like what's happening but our decision
will be based on hard facts and data as
to the opening I'm also hopeful to have
Americans working again by that Easter
that beautiful Easter day but rest
assured every decision we make is
grounded solely in the health safety and
well-being of our citizens this is a
medical crisis this isn't a financial
crisis but it's a thing that nobody has
seen for many many decades nothing like
this marshalling our economic strength
is a key feature of defeating the virus
producing the material supplies and
equipment that we need and they're doing
a really fantastic job we're helping the
governors where the conference call the
other day with the governors and we
allowed the press to join us on the call
and the spirit between us and the
governor's has been really great we
should never be reliant on a foreign
country for the means of our own
survival I think we've learned a lot
we've learned a lot this crisis has
underscored just how critical it is to
have strong borders and a robust
manufacturing sector for three years
we've embarked on a great national
project to secure immigration system and
bring back our manufacturing jobs we've
brought back many jobs records numbers
of record numbers of jobs and this
really shows this experience shows how
important borders are without borders
you don't have a nation our goal for the
future must be to have American medicine
for American patients American supplies
for American hospitals and American
equipment for our great American heroes
now both parties must unite to ensure
the United States is truly an
independent
in every sense of the word energy
independence we've established that and
something incredible that we've
established where energy independent
manufacturing independence economic
independence and territorial
independence enforced by strong
sovereign borders America will never be
a supplicant nation we will be a proud
prosperous independent and self-reliant
nation we will embrace commerce with all
but we will be dependent on none above
all we know that the best thing for our
economy and the world right now is a
very very powerful victory over the
virus every day the American people are
showing the unity and resolve that is
always defined the character of our
nation in New York citizens are using 3d
printers to make hundreds of face
shields they're making them by the
hundreds in Texas businesses and
churches are uniting to collect loves
and thermometers for hospitals in these
selfless actions of our amazing citizens
we're seeing enduring strength of our
magnificent nation a spirit that can
never be broken and a victorious future
that can never be denied it never will
be denied now what I'd like to do is
perhaps ask a person who has really
established herself as maybe the world's
great expert on what she does if I could
ask Debra to come forward and say a few
words and then I'll ask Tony to come up
and speak and then our vice president
and they will take a few questions and
we'll do it quickly and we'll probably
see you again tomorrow so Debra please I
think those of you who heard the
townhall we are continuing to accelerate
testing at a record rate we now have 370
thousand tests that have been done
majority of those over 220,000 in the
last eight days which of those of you
have been tracking the South Korea
numbers put us equivalent to what they
did in eight weeks that we did in eight
days this was made possible because of
the HHS team working together bringing
together the strength of the FDA with
the CDC and the under the leadership of
secretary azar we're very proud of those
numbers but we know that we have to do
more and we continue to accelerate and
testing to ensure that the those who
need the tests are tested first and have
access as we talked about yesterday
we're working on the ability for people
to take their own sample that does not
mean home testing that means taking your
own sample in the front of your nose
with available swabs into normal saline
that can be transplanted it's
transported to the laboratories that
will allow and free up all of the
drive-throughs to see very sparing on
PPE because you'll be able to do that
with gloves rather than the full PPE
outfits this will allow for more that
PPE to be dedicated to our hospitals I
think those of you are tracking this
epidemic closely like I am you will
begin to see that there is encouraging
results coming out of Italy we are
impressed by the the decreases that are
seen in mortality the number of people
succumbing to this illness and the
number of new cases our new cases will
continue to surge because we're still
working on our backlog although we will
be in touch with the laboratories after
this press conference to really find out
how many are still in backlog and how
many were run in the last 24 hours until
we can get into a 24 hour cycle we're
gonna have disproportional number of new
cases compared to the actual new cases
and we will let you know when we've
reached that equilibrium finally and I
know dr. pouchy will talk about this
further we remain deeply concerned about
New York City and the New York metro
area about 56% of all the cases in the
United States are coming out of that
metro area and 60% of all the new cases
are coming out of the Metro New York
and 31% of the peoples are coming to
this disease it means because they still
are at the 31 percent mortality compared
to the other regions of the country that
we can have a huge impact if we unite
together this means as in all places
they have to be following the
presidential guidelines that were put
out eight or nine days ago and this will
be critical but to everyone who has left
New York over the last few days because
of the rate of the number of cases you
may have been exposed before you left
New York and I think like governor de
Santos has put out today everybody who
was in New York should be self
quarantine for the next 14 days to
ensure that the virus doesn't spread to
others no matter where they have gone
whether it's Florida North Carolina or
out too far far reaches of Long Island
we are starting to see new cases across
new across Long Island that suggests
people have left the city so this will
be very critical that those individuals
do self quarantine in their homes over
these next 14 days to make sure they
don't pass the virus to others based on
the time that they left New York so if
they've already are four days out then
it's just ten more days so I thank you
if you helped get that message out to
others dr. pouchy thank you very much it
was the president's depth I want to just
talk very briefly about two or three
things first the issue of testing and
how that has really changed the
complexion of the approach that we'll
gonna be able to take we right know
testing was an issue we had many
questions of testing in this room for a
number of times now that we literally
have hundreds and hundreds of thousands
of testing out there there are a few
things that we can do with that one of
the things is that when we make policy
about what we're going to be doing with
the rest of the country particularly
those areas that are not hotspots we
need to know what the penetrance of
infection is there so we need to put a
light on those dark spots that we don't
know
we have to act policy-wise on data and
we're going to be getting more data a
lot more data the other thing is
the areas of the country that are not
hotspots that are not going through the
terrible ordeal that New York and
California and Washington State are
going through they still have a window
of a significant degree of being able to
contain in other words when you test you
find somebody you isolate them you get
them out of circulation and you do the
contact tracing when you have a big
outbreak it's tough to do anything but
mitigation we have an opportunity now
that we have the availability of testing
to do that so you're gonna be hearing
more about how we can inform where we're
going particularly because we have the
ability to test the second thing is they
just want to reiterate what dr. Berg
said about New York if it's a very
serious situation they've suffered
terribly through no fault of their own
but what we're seeing now is that
understandably people want to get out of
New York they're going to Florida
they're going to Long Island to go into
different places the idea if you look at
the statistics it's disturbing
about one per thousand of these
individuals are infected that's about
eight to ten times more than in other
areas which means when they go to
another place for their own safety
they've got to be careful monitor
themselves if they get sick bring it to
the attention of a physician get tested
also the idea about self isolating for
two weeks will be very important because
we don't want that to be another seeding
point to the rest of the country
wherever they go and then thirdly just
one wouldn't just comment about about
drugs and the testing of drugs you know
the you heard yesterday about drugs
being out there that physicians on an
off-label way can prescribe it to give
people hope of something that hasn't
been definitively proven to work but
that might have some hope
I don't want anybody to forget that
simultaneously without doing that we're
also doing randomized clinical trials on
a number of candidates
you've heard about candidates but there
are others in the pipeline where we'll
be able to design the study and over a
period of time particularly since we
have so many infections we'll be able to
determine definitively are these safe
and are they effective we're talking
about room Dissidia
other drugs immune Sara convalescent
Sarah monoclonal antibodies all of these
are in the pipeline now queuing up to be
able to go into clinical trial so I'll
stop there and we're gaining great
progress on this phase three legislation
negotiations continue we've had
continued reports I've been up there
with secretary of inertia and secretary
munition continues today with the chief
of staff mark meadows checking in with
the president they were getting closer
and closer they expect to vote as soon
as possible I just want to walk through
a couple of key points
this legislation is urgently needed to
bolster the economy provide cash
injections and liquidity and stabilize
financial markets to get us through a
difficult period a difficult and
challenging period in the economy facing
us right now but also to position us for
what I think can be an economic rebound
later this year we started the year very
strong and then we got hit by the corona
virus in ways that probably nobody
imagined possible we're dealing with
that as best we can
this package will be the single largest
main street assistance program in the
history of the united states the single
largest main street assistance program
in the history united states phase two
delivered the sick leave for individuals
hourly workers families and so forth
phase three a significant package for
small businesses loan guarantees will be
included we're going to take out
expenses and lost revenues as the
president said eligibility requires
worker retention we will maintain the
people eligible will maintain their
payrolls during this crisis period and
on top of that we will have direct
deposit checks of roughly $3,000 for a
family of four and that will
Brij to enhanced plus DUP unemployment
insurance benefits that will essentially
take those up to full wages this is one
two three four you know a strong
workforce requires strong business can't
have a job without a business to work
for and hope here is that the companies
that are operating very well at the
beginning of the year when the economy
was in good shape we will help them and
their employees get through this tough
period so they will come out the other
side let's say this later this spring or
summer and will continue their
operations that's the key point
now don't forget there's income tax
deferrals for individuals and
corporations without interest in
penalties there's student loan interest
and principal deferrals without any
penalties and finally I want to mention
the Treasury's exchange stabilization
refund that will be replenished it's
important because that fund opens the
door for Federal Reserve firepower to
deal a broad-based way throughout the
economy for distressed industries for
small businesses for financial
turbulence you've already seen the Fed
take action they intend to take more
action and in order to get this we have
to replenish the Treasury's emergency
fund it's very very important not
everybody understands that that fund by
the way will be overseen by an oversight
board and an Inspector General it will
be completely transparent so the total
package here comes to roughly six
trillion dollars two trillion direct
assistance roughly four trillion in
federal reserve lending power again
it'll be the largest Main Street
financial package in the history of the
United States liquidity and cash for
families small businesses individuals
unemployed to keep this thing going
we're headed for a rough period but it's
only going to be weeks we think weeks
months not gonna be years that's for
sure and hopefully pave the way for
continued economic recovery after this
crisis
thank you thank you I've been hearing
that voice for so many years like 30
years or more maybe and it's a great
voice that it's a great man
so Larry Kudlow thank you very much I
want to say that that package and we
went over parts of it but pretty big
parts it really sets us up to I think
even supersede where we were a month ago
I think we can get up there quickly and
I think it allows us to supersede it
allows us to help these great companies
that need help like Boeing which is you
know had a problem and then on top of
that problem it had the virus come in
but we'll be helping Boeing we'll be
helping the airline's we'll be helping
the cruise lines we'll be doing a lot of
things and the money will all come back
to us and it'll come back to us in a
very strong form and before we take some
questions I'd like to ask our great vice
president to say a few words if you
wouldn't live this Thank You mr.
president the White House coronavirus
task force met again today and on behalf
of the President of the United States
everyone on our team
I know state leaders let me just say
thank you America people across this
country businesses large and small are
responding to the threat of the corona
virus in ways that are deeply inspiring
people are acting on the president's 15
days to slow the spread and it's making
a material difference our experts
standing beside us told us that if every
American and regardless of whether
you're in an area that's impacted by an
outbreak of the corona virus or not if
every American would embrace these
guidelines that we could significantly
reduce the number of Americans that
would contract the corona virus and
protect the most vulnerable and as the
president reflected earlier tens of
millions of Americans are doing just
that
and we're grateful the focus of our task
force of course is to slow the spread to
promote mitigation strategies beyond
that though the president has us focus
on testing and on supplies and making
sure that those that are enduring the
symptoms of the
Rhona virus and those who are
ministering to them our extraordinary
health care workers have the support
that they need in the category of
supplies you just heard dr. Burks
indicate that we've made great progress
we have done more tests in the last
eight days then we're done in the
previous eight weeks and it's because of
the public-private partnership that the
president forged with commercial labs
and I would encourage people around the
country to remind your family members
and friends if you don't have symptoms
don't get a test we want to make sure
people who are having symptoms who have
a concern I have the ability to be
tested and to have those tests process
we're continuing to urge all county
hospitals all labs around the country to
report to the CDC all the results of the
tests as it'll give these experts around
us the ability to continue to advise the
President on best practices as I
mentioned we we all continue to follow
this the outbreak around the country and
the test results but as several have
mention were particularly focused on on
New York the reality is the New York
metro area was 60% of the new cases in
the country and specifically as a
layperson I can tell you that the
infection rates are roughly one in 1,000
in the New York City metropolitan area
where they are 0.2% per thousand or 0.1%
four thousand in places like Washington
State it is the reason why today the
White House coronavirus task force is
calling on any American first and
foremost if you're in the New York City
metropolitan area or elsewhere to take
the guidelines that we issued and avoid
non-essential travel but for anyone in
the New York metropolitan area who has
traveled our task force is encouraging
you to monitor your temperature be
sensitive to symptoms and we are asking
anyone who has traveled out of the New
York City metropolitan area
anywhere else in the country to self
isolate for 14 days we have to deal with
the new york city metropolitan area as a
high-risk area and for that reason we're
we're taking these steps and ask you for
the cooperation of the american people
because of the spread in new york city
we will continue to surge resources the
president's describe this FEMA is
coordinating with New York State for the
arrival of the USS comfort in just a
matter of a few short weeks over the
next 24 hours more than 4,000 additional
ventilators will be delivered to a New
York State as well New York State has
prioritized three alternative medical
facilities and at the president's
Direction the Army Corps of engineer is
working on plans to build those
facilities out you've heard the
president speak about the Javits Center
the addition of a thousand beds and will
continue I want the people of New York
City and the Greater New York City area
to know that we're with you we're going
to continue to provide resources to
support your state and local officials
as they confront the spread of the
corona virus in that great city on the
subject of supplies we had team meetings
today at FEMA which is working on
identifying the critical personal
protective equipment and ventilators at
this point FEMA informs us today that
they are distributing 7.6 million n95
respirator masks more than 14 million
surgical masks and FEMA has already
shipped 73 pallets of personal
protective equipment to New York 36
pallets of personal protective equipment
to the state of Washington we'll be
meeting again tonight as you know the
president stood FEMA is a National
Response Center up and they are in the
lead for the the approach to the corona
virus which is locally executed state
managed and federally supported and will
continue to surge those resources and
make sure that they're available one
last word if I may the president
selected on the response of businesses
around the country have brought to this
moment
it truly is extraordinary the president
did initiate the defense production act
last week but as a president has
reflected many times we will use the
defense production act if we need it to
mandate production of of critical
supplies but so far no one has said no
and in fact we see industries stepping
up president mentioned Ford Motor
Company working with 3m and GE health to
expand production of medical supplies
we heard the McDonald's is now offering
curbside delivery to truckers or unable
to use the drive-through to pick up a
Big Mac and I spoke today and president
spoke last week with Tim Cook of Apple
and at this moment in time Apple went to
their storehouses and is donating nine
million n95 masks to health care
facilities at all across the country and
to the national stockpile there is a
level of generosity that I know is
inspiring to the President and it's
truly inspiring to all of us who are
working on the White House coronavirus
task force president's made it clear
that he hopes in weeks not months to be
able to open up the country but let me
make one last encouragement to every
American we will get to that day quicker
if every American will put into practice
the president's coronavirus guidelines
for our nation 15 days to slow the
spread if every American will do this I
have no doubt that we will slow the
spread we will protect our most
vulnerable and we will heal our land
you just reiterated that you hope to
have the country reopened by Easter and
you said earlier you would like to see
churches packed on that day my question
is you have two doctors on stage with
you have either of them told you that's
a realistic timeline we're looking at a
timeline we've discussed to get we're a
very good meeting today you know if you
add it all up
that's probably nine days plus another
two and a half weeks it's a period of
time that's longer than the original two
weeks so we're gonna look at it we'll
only do it if it's good and maybe we do
sections of the country we do large
sections of the country that could be
two but they were very much in touch
with Tony and with Deborah it's a great
day it was based on a certain level of
weeks from the time we started and it
happened to arrive actually we were
thinking in terms of sooner I'd love to
see it come even sooner but I just think
it would be a beautiful timeline if you
look at what we've just seen in last day
or so you've seen the number of known
coronavirus cases in the country double
in just two days
another 95 people have died just in the
last 24 hours
New York New York's governor is saying
this is spreading like a bullet train
across the country and the governor of
Louisiana is saying that his country
that his state I may not be able to
handle the cases that they're facing by
the by only April so what are you seeing
in all of this that leads you to think I
will learn reopen by mr. even earlier
shift we're working with all of them we
can be talking about large sections of
our country because there are sections
of our country that you didn't talk
about that are doing unbelievably well
they have very little incidents or
problem very small numbers it's very
possible that they won't be ever subject
to what's happening in New York New York
is definitely a hotspot there's no
question about it and you know what
we're doing in New York to try and help
and I think we're doing an incredible
job we're gonna have the hospitals up
quickly the Medical Center's also
quickly
but we'll just have to see we have to
follow what we have to see we're going
to look at that curve we're gonna see
what it starts coming down and we'll do
the best job they can be done judge
please push your penis to president dr.
bad super good just looking at this idea
of an Easter time line and I don't know
that's probably flexible what are the
metrics by which you will make the
decision as to whether you can say yes
we can open up this area of the country
or no we can't open up that area I mean
well you'd be looking at disease numbers
well you've been looking at possible
containment isolation my people will be
looking at a lot of things we'll also be
looking again at very large portions of
our country and I will be guided very
much by dr. Fauci and by Deborah and by
some of the other professionals that
work with both of you and we're gonna
see what what will be but that would
certainly be I think that's a a goal
that perhaps can happen or at least for
a very large portion of our country
since says the president said you and
dr. Burks and others will be guiding him
and making the decision where are you
now this time we'll have 19 days from
now so that's really very flexible we
just had a conversation with the
president in the Oval Office talking
about you know you can look at a date
but you got to be very flexible and on
that on it literally day-by-day and
week-by-week basis you need to evaluate
the feasibility of what you're trying to
do and John you asked for you know what
kind of metrics what kind of data when
you look at the country I mean obviously
no one is gonna want to tone down things
where you see what's going on in a place
like New York City I mean I mean that's
just you know good public health
practice and common sense but the
country is a big country and there are
areas of the country and I and I refer
to this in my opening remarks that we
really need to know more about what the
penetrance is there so if we do the kind
of testing what we're doing and testing
will always be associated by
identification isolation and contact
tracing and you find after a period of
time that there are areas that are very
different from other areas of the
country you may not want to essentially
treat it as a just one force for the
entire country
but look like flexibility in different
areas so I think people might get them
as
interpretation you're just gonna lift
everything up and even somebody's going
like that yeah I mean that that's not
gonna happen
it's gonna be looking at the data and
what we don't have right now that we
really do need is we need to know what's
going on in those areas of the country
where there isn't an obvious outbreak is
there something underneath the surface
that says wait a minute you better be
careful and really clamp down or what
looks there that you don't really have
to be as harsh as you are in other areas
so it's looking at information that up
to this point John we never had so it's
a flexible situation certainly is by far
the if you call it hot if you call it
any word you want to use it is at a
level that I was speaking to Tony before
it's a level that no place else is close
it's very unfortunate you know one of
the things that this happened that we've
done I think a really good job on I
think that it's something special what's
happened is I learned from dr. Burks a
little while ago when she said I learned
it actually this afternoon
in eight days because we kept hearing
about South Korea they had a very tough
time at the beginning if you remember in
eight days we're doing more testing than
they've done in eight weeks that's a
tremendous turn and with our testing
it's going exponentially it's going up
up up every day so we're gonna be able
to do things with this very highly
sophisticated testing and it's also the
test itself is considered the best test
so on top of doing now more than anybody
else we have a very high quality test
that makes a big difference it also
makes a big difference even in terms of
opening because we're gonna see those
areas like the hot spots but New York
City definitely is a very hot spot Steve
when you talk about areas that you could
all about what specifically are you
looking at what states are you talking
about out west you can talk about
we're the farm belt and take a look at
the farm bill take a look at the areas
out west look at big sections of Texas I
was talking to the great governor of
Texas they've done a fantastic job out
there but they're very big sections of
Texas where you know it's it's like
numerous states frankly but we can have
large sections of if we want to do it
that way we can have large sections of
the country open I think it's very
important that we start moving on that
and start thinking about it because a
country wants to be open or people want
it to be open and they wanted they want
they're raring to go and I think it's
one of the reasons that we're gonna have
a tremendous bounce-back I think it's
gonna go very quickly also I want to
thank while I'm here I want to thank
Larry for the job he's done Steve
minuchin for the job is done if you look
at Peter Navarro he's sort of doing
different things he's really he's a
force in terms of getting masks and
getting all of the ventilators and all
the things he's been fantastic Peter but
I also want to thank Congress because
whether or not we're happy that they
haven't quite gotten there yet they have
been working the long hours I'm talking
Republicans and Democrats all of them
the house the Senate I want to thank
Congress because they are really trying
to get there and I think they will and
I'll see you all tomorrow thank you very
much